when you're in the media and out of
ideas you resort to the smear and when
the smear of a leader doesn't provide
you with that dopamine hit you expand
your attack to include anyone who
supports the guy you want a hammer
remember the deplorable is a word meant
to describe 60 million people well now
we got a new one
hey everyone those Trump supporters they
sure seem like a cult don't they the
word cult has been popping up more and
more thinking back to two weeks ago on
this program Anthony scaramouche II and
I talked about his claim that Trump
supporters are in a cult just last week
dan Rather said he thinks support for
Trump seems increasingly cultish and
this weekend in the Washington Post
Trump critic and her hosting strategist
John Weaver said the GOP is not a party
anymore in the traditional sense it's a
cult so nearly half the country is a
cult that's weird
we'll call it America and that cult
people believe in free-thinking
truth and justice it's their way I mean
usually a cult is defined as a smaller
extreme group that demands Allegiance
and secrecy kind of like CNN but now to
that network it encompasses everyone who
doesn't watch CNN ie nearly all of
America who must plug their ears at the
airport bar to avoid Don lemons whining
but Trump's in good company the cult
smear is what political losers embrace
when they can't explain to themselves
why they're still losing many leaders
have supporters who are passionate but
also feed off the relentless negativity
of the press I know I do need I remind
you that over 90% of trumps media
coverage is hysterically against him its
lockstep journalism one that demands
adherence if it were only obvious it is
almost like a Dear Leader situations
like a cult of personality cultish
devotion or the cult the destructive
cult you say the president is using
mind-control become a cult view yourself
or in a cult it's that's a cult it is
frightening to hear a cult expert say
that you see all these signs right now
today in American politics what's that
sound like mr. Stelter Arnon Harry
Krishna looks like your programming
could use some deprogramming
a good one not Airy Krishna I give that
to Dana alright so I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you that I have used this cheap
shot before when I was when I was
describing the media under Obama but I
wasn't describing his supporters I was
surprised I was how like there was an 8
year coma
where nobody covered anything that Obama
did scandal was so that to me was a cult
but I wouldn't go after half the country
who loved him especially if you want to
win again yes so do you remember after
the 2016 election but there was a series
of articles lasted about 18 months where
reporters and went out on a journey to
America yes try to understand all of
these voters especially the voters that
had voted for Obama but then voted for
Trump and and that to me that is about a
cry for help that we need change we need
something different it's not about being
a you know a what it was a what did
Hillary Clinton call them deplorable
horrible like a deplorable person and
actually if you if you look at a lot of
the candidates aren't doing this now and
especially mayor Pete in all of his
interviews it he's constantly saying I
get it let's try to work together he's
trying to be that person that will bring
people together not push them apart like
deplorable yeah one you could argue that
the people that were talking about Obama
supporters being cultish are missing his
appeal and missing the reason why he won
and all that stuff and you could I would
say that it's the same here that if you
dismiss supporters as koltes then you
will always miss the reason why he won
yeah if you were trying to diminish
people and say oh you're just locked in
but I do think there's a reason they're
saying this Greg and it's sort of hard
politics which is that I think it was
Wall Street journal/nbc when they did
polling and asked Republicans are you
more loyal to the Republican Party or to
President Trump the answer came back
like more than 50 percent said my lawyer
athletes to President Trump and I think
it's about 35% said Mylo at least the
Republican Party and that's why you see
a lot of the top Republicans on Capitol
Hill say we can't challenge Donald Trump
because Trump controls the party I think
you're right or than the party so that's
I mean so you could say oh well you know
they're saying there are all zombies but
no I think there's something else and so
you
it's like with Trump either you're 100%
behind Trump or you're 0% so I would say
to you you know like tell me three
things anybody around here disagrees
with Trump Oh strongly disagree with
that Trump's a terrible cult leader he's
getting rebuked by Republicans all the
time Syria the Kurds tariff this guy
gets killed by his own party constantly
the RNC wanted nothing to be over for
the election you can't McCain you got
wrongly switched parties people are
retiring this guy has some sort of locks
is the entire Republican said oh it's an
illegal yeah rush of the Ukraine
independence bailed on the experience in
a cult being a fan of the Oakland
Raiders Raiders fans are heavily heavily
behind their team yeah do you see the
Trump supporters ago - I took one's
wants point though why not be loyal to
the person who does a better job like if
you think that Trump is doing a better
job and not the Republican Party yeah
but you're loyal to people not to a
thing yeah yeah I've been loyal things I
was told that I was in a cult because I
was in a sorority in college look it's
all that's true it's always something
well you did slaughter that goat was a
sacrifice
he was young but it's it's so simple to
alienate people and I think what I don't
understand is the continued failure to
grasp how that elitist name-calling
talking down patronizing mentality is
exactly the reason why people who
support Trump feel heard by him and why
they continue to support him and why
they continue to feel disconnected from
these talking heads and the mainstream
media and the people that are
controlling the Democratic Party it's so
simple I don't understand why it
continues to fly by the eyes of everyone
in charge all right well that's a good
way to end this segment don't you thank
wonderful as well all right